- [Instructor] Get up from that chair
because doctors say that walking
for even two minutes every hour
can have a significant
impact on you're health.
So, we've underlined you're
and this is strange
because you apostrophe re,
this is a contraction for you are.
And so, we should just be able
to replace it with you are
and see if it makes sense
because doctors say that even walking
for two minutes every hour
can have a significant impact
on you are health.
That clearly doesn't make any sense.
I am not health.
So, let's rule out
keeping it the way it it.
And the intention here was to have your,
the second person possessive.
Your health, whose health?
Your health.
So, this is something that you have,
you have your health,
so this is what was intended
and they sound the same
but they're spelled differently.
We want Y-O-U-R.
Yours health, that
doesn't even sound right
or a significant impact on their health.
Their health doesn't make sense
because they're telling,
the sentence is speaking
to the second person,
it's saying get up from that chair,
speaking directly to a person.
So, if I'm speaking directly to a person,
I would say hey you,
I wouldn't say, them, or their health,
so I would rule out these two as well.
So, very important to realize
this your versus you're,
this is one of the the most
common grammar mistakes,
I would say your versus you're
is up there with their versus there
and its and it's
versus it's
and in all of these cases,
these are possessive
pronouns right over here
and these are other things
and this one over here
and this one over here,
these are contractions
and there, this is in
references to something,
this is kind of saying a location,
here or there or there are so many things,
this is a possessive.
So, these are good ones to know
and I think even the best of folks
have made this mistake
when they're typing an email really fast
and so, it's definitely a good
thing to keep a close eye on.